عندما تقع في ازمه وضيق نفسيه ستجد من
يوسيك ويرفع من معنوياتك لتخطي الامر منهم
من يطلق عبارات التحفيز بروح التفاؤل
ويدعون دائما الى تمسك بالنظره الايجابيه
حيا لكل شيء هذا شيء حميد لكن خبر عالم
النفس اكدوا ان التظاهر بالتفاؤل بشكل
دائم قد ينقلب لتعاسه تشير دراساتهم الى
ان مصطلح الايجابيه السامه او الايجابيه
الزائفه هو تجاهل الامور التي يجب
مواجهتها ما يتسبب لكافه المشاعر وعدم
التعامل معها بالشكل الصحيح
[موسيقى]
متى تتحول الشخصيه الايجابيه الى شخصيه
السامه
سهام كل شيء زيدان صح فلما نصير كتير كتير
يعني ننكر انه نعترف انه في اشياء مش
مزبوطه في اشياء سلبيه عم بتصير بالحياه
ونحن عندنا هذه لا كل شيء تمام
[موسيقى]
نعم نكبت مشاعرنا
ووو
منفرج انه همم في شيء مش مضبوط ونخبيها
المشاعر تحت تحت السجاده او بالجرور مثل
ما بيقولوا مفكرين انه راح تختفي فجاه ما
راح تصير هيك همم لازم نحنا
اخصائيين لعلم النفس الايجابي نعترف انه
في اشياء مش مزبوطه او في اشياء سلبيه
ونوقف عندها
احنا بشر يا فاتن ساعات الظروف او المشاكل
تكون اكبر منه اكبر من طاقتنا في هذه
الحاله كيف يمكن ان نتعامل بايجابيه من
دون ما نكون تكوني ايجابيه زائفه يعني انت
عامل مع المشاكل بيروح الجميع اوكي هلا في
عندنا اكيد همم
مثل همم
يعني همم حالات بتكون صعبه ان احنا همم
نتعامل مع فكيف فينا نتعامل مع الطريقه
غريبه
مره نتماغنا لانه نشوف
الاشياء الكويسه من الموضوع همم وبتصير هي
تمرين للدماغ انه نشوف الكبايه نصف مليان
مش الفاضي همم
مثل ما بقولوا كل كل غيمه في لها سيلفر
فنشوف وين هذا النور همم
[موسيقى]